Hallo und herzlich.
Und.
Hallo Tim.
Glaube, dass es.
Hoffentlich.
Kann schon sein.
Ich glaube, das.
Mhm.
Und.
Was.
Um's gleich mal.
Abgesehen.
Die wollen wir uns.
Zwei Jahren.
Also hätten jetzt.
Hätte das.
Gut und bisher.
Und.
Welle
eigentlich seit
sind
ja jetzt
ge
7 Tagen,
erheblich
der.
Was war denn die.
Ja zuletzt.
Ich glaube
harmlos,
äh glaube ich,
einen PC
ja
Und ich ich.
Zu
Drei bis.
Bis.
Ne
Gesunkene,
Okay, also gehen.
Toten.
Vor dem,
zu vergleich,
Winter
der Inzi.
Jetzt tatsächlich
auch viele.
Einfach
müsst.
Im Verhält.
Der
natürlich.
Aber.
Kann man da auch noch.
R-Wert.
Gefallen,
zwei
der,
Varia.
Äh
ja Gegen.
Ja den.
In dem Bereich.
Während.
Entwickelt.
Runter.
Äh drama
dass es insgesamt.
Eben was mit.
Erwähnt hast.
Village Po.
UK zu.
Deutlich länger,
zeichnet sich,
wieder so,
irgendein.
Ja
Du hast aber auch,
rechnen, ne
aber nicht
dass es
eine andere Inter.
Ja, ja,
von,
nennenswert
alle
vorher
ist das.
Wie gesagt.
Okay und was ist mit.
Genau.
Sterblichkeit.
Schon.
Während wir,
drei.
Auch noch.
Aber.
Ja äh.
Dem
wo wir
und jetzt.
In deiner.
Äh ja gut.
Ist es.
Okay.
Alphawelle.
Aber äh
Faktor.
Achtzig
runter.
In
Mhm. Um.
Ja mit.
Mit P.
Und.
Faktor.
Zahlen ja.
Natürlich auch.
Infiz.
Nur noch.
Sagen.
Da müsste man.
Okay, also.
Dieser.
Ende,
hochkletter.
Wackelig.
Sagen wir's mal so
und dann,
ging das Ding.
Für den.
Und für die anderen.
Irgendwas.
Ja.
Summa summarum.
Im Ansatz.
Und im Zusammen.
Aber die ist sehr.
Grade jetzt,
zu erwart,
das dann hier,
volllaufen.
Man kann.
Zur Gri.
Altersgruppe
aber
ist es jetzt
irgendwie,
nicht.
Ja und wir haben.
Also man kann sich.
Noch.
Erstens,
in Kontakt.
Und.
Weil das lässt.
Auch die Impf.
Gut.
Ja ja.
Äh lage
äh der,
infiz
wird es
schon mal.
Natürlich.
Also äh.
Der Bevölk.
Ja
Genau,
bei
noch ge.
Geimpf.
Kann man auch natürlich.
Leute, die
ne? Das
nicht unbedingt.
Ja
Die Gruppen.
Gibt's jetzt.
Wo
Dress.
Ja plus.
Wie's bei.
Genau.
Zwanzig.
Also jung,
also
äh
Höchstens.
Sogar.
Weil,
ja mehr.
Denke ich.
So
Wer jetzt noch,
Also,
da sind.
ein.
Wird sich dann.
Muss und.
Wenn die.
Mir doch egal.
Ne, weil das ist.
Höre ich schon wieder.
Wird,
sicherlich noch.
Bin da nicht der.
Auch die.
Können und
Booster.
Nachricht
Das,
im im.
Oder,
Insofer.
Kriegst es gar.
Tja.
Ausverkauf.
Genau.
Dann,
Vielleicht.
Ob es im.
Weil das ja jetzt.
Uns das dann
Covid.
Bei den meisten.
Noch mal so.
Also klar,
so ist es halt.
Es gibt ja so.
Tue mir langsam.
Es ist auch überhaupt.
Mega.
Das obwohl
et cetera PP
Zuschauer.
Trotzdem.
Da so um die.
Glücklich.
Ge
eine,
aber ist halt nicht.
Konnte sich relativ.
Zu kriegen, weil.
Aber es war eben.
Ist halt.
Man das nochmal.
Hat sich.
Irgendwo.
Super ansteck.
Vorteil,
krassen.
Natürlich,
infiz.
So
Kann man
muss.
Nicht no.
Rechnung,
oder
über die,
in
Dadurch.
Schweden
ist es
und
äh
äh würde
ja
durchgekommen
da
Fast doppelt
aber
äh in den
oder ja
ähm alle,
kann man,
das.
Und vor.
Am besten.
Norwegen am.
Wie fern.
Todesfälle.
Insbesonder.
Wobei ich einfach.
Zero co.
Vor.
Da wär.
Senken,
zweiten.
Weniger.
Jetzt so.
Also wir
ein bisschen
äh
Genau. Das ist aber.
Unserer.
Infektions.
Kam hier gleich.
Irgendwelche,
sieht
Dann,
außer.
Euch diese Zahl
aus dem Siro.
Da hatten wir so.
Nur so.
Sie noch,
abgesehen.
Erfass.
Wo halt.
Gestorben.
Also wo du.
Relatet,
gestor,
Ne, also wo's.
Wenn.
Quasi einen.
Du hattest.
Wie,
wieder um und.
Wirklich auf.
Maximal
Fälle
der.
Also ich habe bisher.
Toten, wo man.
Und.
Drinstehen.
Rein,
dem kann man jetzt.
Ich kann ja.
Gibt's keinerlei.
Ausfallen,
Man muss abwä,
wirtschaftlicher.
Betrifft.
Niemandem,
So, das ist.
Okay, wir.
Das mag teil.
Ist.
Zum Ende kommen.
Natürlich,
jetzt bei
Als grund,
sowie,
zu sehen
äh
Lockdown.
An
So dann hat,
rum, dass dass,
Länder
dass die
Aber.
Zusammen
angewandt
durchge.
Ja
Das bringt auch so,
wie wir.
Weiß nicht, wie's.
Journal.
Reinge.
Du hast immer noch,
ganz schön
ge
Auch einen,
Brüche.
Die grad.
Mit Rum.
Ich denke
kann halt
Äh und
und
nicht so ausge.
Es
äh we
bei weitem.
Deutlich
kann man sagen,
bewahr.
Dass wir das.
Gut.
Also das das
Pandemie, aber.
Ich.
Aus,
Aber.
Dieses.
Vom Stuhl.
Impfstoff.
Nachdem das.
Hergestellt.
Was zu tun.
Wobei,
um sozusagen,
im Impfstoff.
Verschwör.
Der Groß.
In
Leute,
Wir haben einfach
gelungen,
das hätte wirklich.
Ja
Glaube,
ja
so eine
entweder
oder du darf,
anpassen,
was.
Auch
äh
halt
Corona
Ich sehe,
oder,
Tabuthe.
Vielleicht
aufmachen,
pflegen.
Individuen.
Wir sind, ja
einfach.
Die Hardwa
so
ähm
all die Dinge,
zu krieg,
Sinne,
ja
die Erbsü
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Ich äh.
Aber.
Du bist noch.
Na ja, ich bin,
jetzt äh,
ganz.
Klingt aber.
Ja, musst du.
Mal gucken.
Das wird.
Es passiert
oder
ja
Chris ist eh.
Die wirkt.
Selten
ein gewisse,
wenn man das
durchreich.
Ja, also
total.
Nee, wir müssen.
Das sind auch.
Ja
Wir.
Nee, nee, nee.
Total durch.
Nee, also ich
mir halt
äh
Ja, sagen wir mal.
Und ich.
Partei
äh
dann regel
sich ja auch.
Auch durch I.
Das vielleicht.
Ich habe das.
Ja, also ich habe.
Impfung.
War dann.
Allright Pa.
Ja, hoffen.
Haben wir das.
Gefällig.
Leute,
hier.
Ähm aber.
Macht's gut.